first of all i'm done i'm done
i'm done challenging myself
i'm over it that [ __ ] is stupid you know
when you're young and they tell you oh
you gotta like uh face your fears no
your fears are there to help you
the fears are good okay
i have a fear of heights that's a good
thing
when i look over a side of a building
right i'm not supposed to go that that
looks beautiful
my balls should be in my neck when i
look at the side of the building okay
that's your body's way of saying back up
you [ __ ] idiot
like an idiot i decide to try to conquer
my fear of heist by going skydiving i
don't know if any of you guys have gone
skydiving here anybody you went okay
couple people going scout of it let me
tell you this [ __ ] this is real
skydiving
is the stupidest [ __ ] thing you could
possibly do the best case scenario is
you live
you know what we were doing right before
that living we were living that's what
we were doing why would i pay 300 to
keep [ __ ] doing what i was doing
that's stupid
now
like an idiot i decided to go skydiving
okay i decided to go i asked my friends
i say
you know you guys went did you like it
everybody says i loved it right and i
realized that's because the people who
they didn't really like it that much are
dead okay
they're not around to tell us how shitty
skydiving could be sometimes okay
there are no bad reviews on yelp for
skydiving
because those people hit the ground
before they could go on unsatisfactory
experience
first time you go you have to go is
called tandem tandem means you spend 300
to be a bottom um
so a bottom is the guy in the gay
relationship that gets the dick put in
them okay
so basically a guy in a spandex onesie
i want to point out i didn't ask him to
dress that way i just want to point that
out i didn't send him an email and say
hey you know how you're going to be uh
really close to me tomorrow why don't
you wear something that could fill your
[ __ ] good that'd be perfect
this [ __ ] shows up in lycra head to
toe lycra
did you go bobsledding earlier today
what the [ __ ] is going on
walks up behind me goes i'm gonna strap
you on
whispers in my ear when we jump out of
the plane i just want you to arch your
back
you want me to what yeah we're going to
videotape it no we're not going to
videotape it
i'm not going to have a video so i'm
doing spandex right behind me
i started feeling comfortable
i checked myself okay i said no dude's
dick pushed up against my ass gonna make
me question my sexuality okay i love
chicks nothing's changing that [ __ ]
strap it on onesie let's [ __ ] do this
i didn't realize i'd be going to a
shitty little plane okay and for 15 000
feet there would be constant turbulence
and i'm sitting on this motherfucker's
lap
dropping it like it's hot on his ass for
15 000
hot dog in the bun situation okay
he's whispering in my hair don't forget
your harness your back
this warm ass breath in my [ __ ] ear
shut up shut up
stop it with your warm ass nice breath
in my ear
i start to feel uncomfortable again
okay i check myself once again i say no
dudes dick vibrate him ferociously
against my ass gonna make me question my
sexuality i love chicks nothing's
changed in that [ __ ] let's
do this
we reached the altitude we jumped out
that plane we started to fall
i wish that [ __ ] was inside me
look i'm good
i could not be close enough to that man
he was like arms open i said hold me
[ __ ]
the [ __ ] you mean arms i'm the little
spoon you're the big spoon
we are spooning to safety that's how
this [ __ ]
[Music]
works i don't care if any of you guys
judge me
in that moment i'd be fine if he was
inside me
because at least if he was inside me if
he tried to unbuckle me
i could be like no
you're not going nowhere buddy
i've been doing ass kegels for a month
to prepare for this
you know what i mean it's like i went
skydiving once have you ever done that
no envy has i have yeah okay i i hated
it mm-hmm you know like
what did you hate about it because i i i
hated going up i hate the thought of
jumping
out and you're flying
i enjoyed that part but the whole going
up part i didn't like it because it was
terrifying the entire time like okay i
got it on the plane yeah in the
beginning it's a plane ride then the
door opens yep and you realize you
expect it to jump out and i'm strapped
to a guy that i've never met before and
i didn't see the shoot pack and oh my
god i have kids and all this stuff
you're thinking as you edge up to the
door next thing you know you're just in
the sky there's no logical reason to be
there no there's no you know my life
didn't depend on and yet i jumped out of
this plane
and just falling and everyone says it
feels like flying but to me it felt like
falling about 120 miles
and i was terrified
so what did you get out of the situation
other than being terrified well the
point is when you when the chute lands
and you survive it you go home at night
you eat dinner food tastes better
house is quiet and still and you feel
comfortable and safe in your house
you're like man i'm glad to be home
everything's good so that's what it felt
like it felt like uh coming back and
doing this netflix special and all that
felt like my shoot open and everything's
just good right yeah i don't got to do
all that to get that feeling i'm black
in america all i got to do is just drive
through the neighborhood that i live in
and make it home without being stopped
and i feel that
i live in a much nicer neighborhood
i mean
you know what i mean like i know what
you mean but it's not like i'm going to
try to survive a traffic stop just to
get that feeling i mean it's like
it's the black experience but i did it i
don't know why i did it but the point is
that now
there's just i'm happy to be doing what
i'm doing would you do it again
what quit my show now
no i don't think i would man i mean like
i i get it i know what it's about you
know what i mean i just think that
you know something it's just one of
those things i didn't even mean to do it
the first time it's a long story i told
you that you're running far enough
[Music]
jumping out of a plane
hey bill
where are you at on jumping out of a
plane
uh if you're a chicken [ __ ] american i'm
a brit how much money would it take you
to jump
uh
i got a bet with my mate
that you hate heights and it take 500
000 us dollars don't change your answer
to be contrary to what i just guessed
keep it fair good sir thanks
oh jesus another arrogant brit
these guys think they're [ __ ]
geniuses
um
i've already done it you [ __ ] idiot
and i paid someone to do it
i paid i went to uh in pepperell
massachusetts when i was 19 years old
and i didn't do a tandem jump either i
did a static line jump i've told this
story on the podcast sir
if you're a little bit um
more up on it
and also i have a pilot's license i fly
helicopters
so if i was afraid of heights i mean i'm
afraid of heights look if i don't have a
parachute on my back
and i'm not in a uh
in a vehicle that's designed to fly
then yes i'm afraid of heights like i
don't like uh
you know like if he's like one time i
watched a youtube video
and they just showed these guys that had
to climb up to the top of this [ __ ]
building
and then
no not climbed well they took the
elevator it was getting hot they they
were on the roof
and it was already on the [ __ ] roof
this building was so [ __ ] high up
and you know the wind up there must be
ridiculous i would literally just lay
down in the fetal position and crawl
back to the [ __ ] door that leads to
the stairwell reach up to the handle
and [ __ ] go back down but this this
dude
um
then climbs the [ __ ]
the the whatever the the radio tower or
whatever
and it just keeps getting higher and
higher and higher in in the tower gets
smaller and smaller and smaller and he's
hooking and unhooking his safety line
i literally
i
couldn't i mean obviously the guy lived
because it's his gopro on his helmet
and
i've never been so [ __ ] unsettled
watching something in my life okay then
i would hate heights but i think at that
point
everybody hates heights but um yeah when
i was 19 years old
i went to uh this place uh in pepperell
massachusetts which i don't think exists
anymore there might still be an airport
there and they had a uh
a school
and uh you i did the static line jump if
you've ever seen that movie uh fandango
one of kevin costner's earlier ones
where
the dude from uh breakfast club
uh judd nelson his character jumps out
um that's exactly what i did
and i remember when we went up
the command was sit in the door get out
and then he slapped you on the shoulder
and said go
and uh
i remember when he said sit in the door
i thought he was saying close the door
so i was reaching up i'm sitting down
reaching up trying to close the door and
he had this big smile on his face like
he thought i was chickening out i feel
like i just told this story on the
podcast
and
then i finally realized he was saying
sit in the door so you sit in the door
and basically it's one of those planes
where the the wing
is
above the aircraft you know what it's on
top of the aircraft as opposed to below
which actually gives you a much better
sight i would think um as far as if you
wanted to look down
um and then there's the support that
goes to the side of the plane so and
then right above one of the landing
wheels the wheels don't retract on this
plane they had uh welded a little step
so
you sat in the [ __ ] door
and uh i forget how high we were i want
to say we were only like 1500 we weren't
that high up because your shoot
immediately comes out
um
so you set you sit in the door then he
goes get out and then what you do is you
reach out and you grab that support beam
from the wing and you hold on to that
while one of your feet
is uh is standing on that little step
thing
and then basically what you do is i'm
literally acting this out so i can
remember it is you then basically you
you bend your arms and you bring your
chest like
flush with the support beam
and then the the foot that's dangling
you put it straight out behind you it's
almost like a yoga pose
so sit in the door get out and then he
slaps your shoulder and he goes go
and you let go
and then you you arch you arc right arc
one arc one thousand two one thousand
three one thousand look if nothing look
reach pull and when you're looking
you're looking over your your shoulder
to see if your shoot came out
and then if nothing you look down
at the handle
reach pull it because for some reason
they say if you don't look down
you might be flailing
because you're panicking because it's
the first time you jumped and the shoot
didn't come out
sorry cayenne pepper
hang on a second
so
anyways
i get out
he goes go i let go
and instead of arching i
i don't know what i did i just reached
for something all i know is i started
doing front front flips
as my shoot was coming out
and i felt it go by my leg
the inside of my leg i felt it go by my
leg i
felt something hit that
and i was immediately thinking oh my god
i'm gonna roll right up in this [ __ ]
thing like
you know when you put bacon on shrimp
and uh
the second i had that
thought like the shoot already had come
out and by the grace of god i didn't get
tangled up i think about that sometimes
like
how easily i could have [ __ ] died
um
and then boom your shoe comes out and
when your shoe comes out you don't even
feel like you're falling because there's
nothing going past you because you're
above the tree line and all that so you
just feel like you're just sort of
suspended in the air
and uh there was a radio and this lady
just talked you in do you say pull the
left toggle and you had to pull it all
the way down to your knee because i
remember there was this
this big girl in the class and she
couldn't get it around her hips and she
landed across the street in a pile of
loom and uh dislocated her knee i
remember that before and and then i went
up after her and i was just like [ __ ]
um
and then they have this ridiculous
you know when you get to the tree line
you suddenly realize how fast you're
falling i think it was like 17 feet per
second or maybe 11 feet i can't remember
but it was really fast it was like
basically you know
jumping off of a basketball rim like how
fast you'd come down
it had to be a little bit slower right i
don't know because you're not reaching
terminal velocity i don't [ __ ] know
so all i know is when you hit the ground
what you were supposed to do is look
straight ahead
because for some reason if you look down
at your feet what you were gonna do they
were worried you'd pick your feet up too
quickly and somehow break your legs so
what you had to do is look straight
ahead and as right as you hit the ground
you're supposed to do this little
[ __ ] like collapse down and then this
big ridiculous bring you both your legs
straight up in the air and then over to
your side
i don't know why i doubt that they still
have people do that and i did what
everybody else did is i came down and
the second my feet hit the ground i did
a face plant
right into the grass
and my buddy grabbed the uh the mic from
the person and called me a [ __ ]
something like that what a [ __ ] or
something in the uh
in the in the radio
um so yeah
there you go so i did it and what are
you basing chicken [ __ ] american on
huh
all you tough guys over there with your
fish and chips
have you done it yet
500 years there's nothing you can some
if i don't want to do something i'd i
wouldn't do it there's not money that
you can give me
i know he goes ugh give me a [ __ ]
break no i'm making great money i got
enough money i got enough money i'm good
to take my life in my [ __ ] hands no
that's one of those things now now i was
back working at the warehouse
i mean granted i pay somebody when i was
working in a [ __ ] warehouse i uh
[ __ ] you know let's see
how much were they i mean if they gave
me
literally if you gave me 400 you would
have doubled my pay for the week so i
would have done that
well let's see let's go back to the
building
to climb up that building
how much money would they have to give
me
uh when i was working in the warehouse
uh 800
um
and that now for that that building uh
i would say uh
yeah i just wouldn't do it
that's no i'm all right i'm all set
i'm all set i you know i should actually
send you guys that video
um
so it's not that i hate heights sir i
hate
um
risking my life
to that level if there's like a
parachute or something like that
it is a bungee cord or there's like a
[ __ ] safety line that's fine but you
know going up that tower where i have to
unhook the safety line and then hook it
back up and there's wind and [ __ ] [ __ ]
that that's too much of a risk i
wouldn't do that